[Music]
hello everyone I'm Alexander Rose I'm
the executive director here at the long
now foundation and I'm excited to have
you here we are restarting our normal
seminar series and while we are under a
shelter-in-place order during this
epidemic it has taken us a little bit to
get this restarted this this seminar is
originally scheduled for the end of
March but here we are in April and I'm
very excited to have it I think the idea
of working with the synthetic biology
space during the time of an epidemic
like we're and I believe is important I
think some of the advents of the
technologies that are actually in the
midst of a revolution around us all as
as we speak and I think some of what
Jane is going to speak today will show
you that that that revolution is
happening all around us right now and
she's going to give us a window into
some of those some of the kind of the
bleeding edge of that revolution and it
will allow us to start talking about
some of the ethics that are there and
some of the ways that we might actually
introduce ourselves into that time and
the space to to engage with that so I'm
very excited to to be doing this as our
first seminar back here as we do this in
a virtual format and Jane is also going
to be posing some questions to us all
in all of the various chat windows that
you have whether it be YouTube Twitter
and the one on our on our home page the
lung out org slash live you should have
a chat window that you can answer some
of the questions that she's that she's
posing as well as answer as putting your
own questions and those questions are
going to be copied and pasted to
dock that that kevin kelly who normally
sorts our questions and in our live
events and kevin kelly was one of the
founding editors at at wire or a
founding at her at Wired that that chain
was one of the cofounders of as well so
I think it's it's fitting that he's
going to be he's gonna be editing some
of these questions for you all and
they'll be passed to me through that
duck and I'll be answering those
questions as well as any comments that
you have around some of the questions
that Jane has around the larger issues
of synthetic biology and the nearby
electrical revolution are going to be
passed on to her and her team for for
future edits of her work so I think the
the moment that we are in is important
for synthetic biology and I also am
really excited to be restarting our our
series with Jane this is an important
moment for all of us to be thinking
about the way biology and technology
meet so thank you and we will pass it
over to Jane thank you very much well hi
thank you so much for inviting me I'm
I'm just delighted to be here I have
been a fan of long now since its
inception in fact I'm actually member
number 26 just wanted to you know that
so yeah I'm the fan and of course with
Kevin and Stuart and Esther on wired and
Electronic Frontier Foundation and now
long down along now foundation so all of
you I just have to say have been
enormous ly inspired over the years I'm
such a fan of the mission and and the
execution and so it's a real treat to be
giving my first talk tonight and of
course I would have loved to be on the
stage as with jazz but I think this
format gives us an opportunity to sort
of grow our way through yet new
disruptive technologies but it also
gives us a chance to do something a
little bit different and since I'm the
first one I can do whatever I want right
and then it is basically to engage the
community because you know I am NOT a
really important question for everybody
and I think it's a perfect long nail
question I think it's sort of a Design
Thinking kind of question as well and I
want to pose it to you Neville so that
you can be thinking about it during this
conversation during my remarks you can
start putting your thoughts and your
responses to my question in the live
stream chat rooms wherever you may be
whatever form you may be looking at this
on and and based on business design
thinking so look forward to how
technologies and bio technologies play
out what impact that has on us as humans
as Homo sapiens and imagine what it is
that you want us to evolve into how do
you want us to be using these
technologies and what guidelines what
what concerns what guardrails we need
what hopes and aspirations and dreams do
you have for it but look at what it
looks like in the future and then think
back to where we are today do we need to
be doing now what do we need to be
thinking about talking about planning
for stopping or started there promoting
or what have you so not this vision of
where we go in the future is one that we
can all aspire to it's when we can
manifest as opposed to one that we fear
so the question is we just simplify it
for you
you can answer any one of those you want
but the simplest version of the question
is what are the elements that you think
belong in a manifesto for the future of
our species it's a pretty open-ended
question I'm really looking forward to
your comments and responses if this is
all new to you I'm going to take next
you know 45 minutes or so
about what we're calling the neo
biological frontier which is how
technology is pushing the boundaries of
biology forward and the impact it's
going to have on us as humans and as a
planet and as interconnected biological
systems so then we'll have a chance for
a Q&A at the end and we can discuss your
thoughts on the topic so that's a
question I also have an announcement
so this pin tip is not just taking a
toll on people who are sick with code 19
and the people who are taking care of
them and can we just stop for a minute
and give those people a little bit of
love and a little bit of support and
respect because it's anyone's it's also
wreaking havoc on all the other people
whose lives are being completely upended
by by the quarantine and the shutdown I
know there's lots of organizations that
have sprung up to to help those most at
risk most in need and what I would like
from this committee is your
recommendations on great organizations
local to the Bay Area would be great but
anything you think really need our help
and I will put 25% of of book revenues
at the donation on behalf of the long
nail community to that organization so
in your chat rooms please give us
recommendations of organizations that
you've vetted initiatives that you
believe in we'll take some time tomorrow
and over the weekend and select an
organization long now and we'll update
you and a future newsletter and tell you
which one we selected and all you have
to do to make that happen is go to our
website which is gwneud life by a book
type in long now as your discount code
or promotional code and we will give
plenty 5% of book revenues to that
organization so so I'm looking forward
to this I'm outsourcing your ideas for
it and you know we are talking about the
leading edge and I think the most most
at risk are don't have that lunch
and so people who can't afford to buy
food or pay for their shelter need more
support right now so having said that
over the next five ten and twenty years
they're going to be developments at the
intersection of biology and technology
that will present us with some of the
most profound and vexing choices our
species ever faced and the pulse of
genetic engineering and synthetic
biology are giving us unimaginable
powers and we have even more
capabilities coming down the pike that
are going to completely transform our
species so we've just been brought to
our knees by a single virus and you know
it's essentially a virus so I have to
just acknowledge the irony of that for a
moment
the Czar's covent 2 is making us a
little bit primitive and a little bit
limited but we're learning a lot from
this virus and we have an opportunity to
put our new tools and our understanding
gonna test and I got to tell you we have
come a long way so now I'm going to give
you a forty-six hundred year history
innovation from here exploit 600 BC till
today in about ten minutes and that's
relatively easy because it's mostly a
story about observation until about 150
years ago so we can start with Imhotep
in the year 2600 BC he was an Egyptian
well actually he was known as an
architect he built the the Pyramid of
Java also knows the step pyramid he was
a physician and philosopher which was a
common combination at the time but he
was also a priest because of what
religion was ball racked up with health
at the time he considers ease the result
of natural processes and not acts of
spiteful God or curses or humor to what
have you he be partly not diagnosed
these treatments for 200 diseases in in
base forward mm which is how we get
ten minutes along Hippocrates and
although Hippocratic oath called upon
the God you had to swear to Apollo
Asclepius hygeia and panacea and all the
gods and goddesses when taking a
Hippocratic oath
Hippocrates nevertheless I understood
that medicine could be separated from
religion and philosophy and that disease
was the result of heredity or diet or
environmental factors so he was
important and basically for the next
twenty five hundred years
thanks treat medicine is really a
history of observation you know in the
year 500 BC we discovered veins and
arteries in the year 300 BC we
discovered with discovered invent an
infant but discovered and described the
nervous system in the year 910 ad we
identified smallpox and I say we because
I consider myself a long line of Homo
sapiens who've been trying to deal with
the smallpox cowards
and then we fast-forward to basically
1489 and then she used affecting corpses
but what's really interesting to me is
the Year 1590 when a Dutch father and
son duo named Hassan Sicarius Johnston
basically invented the ultimate
observation tool the microscope they
just put two lenses together in the tube
and we're only able to magnify 3 to 9 X
there was no resolution or fighting and
essentially what they saw was a public
Lurie has no real discoveries came as a
result of it but you know that's what it
looked like a very primitive - and
really as I said but not much was
happening until Antony van Leeuwenhoek
in a year 1676 so 70 some odd years
later 80 so many years later Anthony
from Langevin book as if I just
discovered bacteria so that I think the
toss
the microscope had evolved so that he
could actually see little tiny moving
things which he identified as bacteria
the follow up here in 1677 he discovered
her somebody brought him ejaculate but
it was really another 200 years before
the real importance and significance of
bacteria would start to unfold and that
may be thanks to her and the pester
we get into 18th century and that's when
we start to see interventions for the
first time at the beginning of the
century 1701 the first smallpox in the
in inhalations but they were of course
incredibly dangerous and people would
definitely sick from them in 1763 be the
first appendectomy and then in 1796
Edward Jenner came along and basically
developed the first vaccine so I'm for
smallpox and I'm differentiating a
vaccine from the inoculation for ease of
discussion here she basically has the
photo of an illustration of a cow in his
hand that's because if he noticed that
cow pox was significantly less virulent
than smallpox and used the cow pox
itself as a vaccine against smallpox and
because it was significantly less risky
and and had less native repercussions
the vaccine became much more widely used
even though people can play around
inoculation for 100 years the money was
able to make it safer and sort of in
people's system attacks it so that
basically 4,500 years of medicine before
truly effective treatments were
developed along comes the 19th century
and now we have lots of treatments that
start to happen in 1846 we have the
painting humor that represents the first
use of anesthesia they etherized
this patient to remove a tumor in his
neck that means by the way that that
first step in debt to me was done
without without anesthesia
19th Street also saw
human blood fusions for the first time
incredibly adventurous we developed
contact lenses in 1887 in 1895 extracts
were discovered but really matters here
for the purposes of discussion tonight
was the development of germ theory and
at the first forward about the 1860s
Louis Pasteur on the right was working
with tuberculosis and he identified
bacteria as the source of the disease
and began developing vaccines against it
and so he fact began whole processes of
the study of vaccination he's considered
the father of microbiology and he also
pushed the whole field of
microbiological microbe right sorry
microbial fermentation forward and then
course Christianisation along comes port
cop now Robert and Petr were not great
friends in fact they had quite a bit of
sneering of chillers Berg especially
of pastures work but Congress the
one who basically created the
experiments and the the scientific
process the methodology that proved that
tuberculosis was caused by the
particular bacteria also cholera and
anthrax and he really was kind of the
father of this idea of infectious
diseases by in addition to that he was
an amazing inventor he was the one who
first invented
Eggar as the medium that would feed
cells in a petri dish so that we could
study cells outside of the body it was
also the first to develop staining of
those cells so that we could see what
was happening to appreciate them from
another and as a result of his work a
huge impact on the whole field or
concept of Public Health and he was
involved in passing legislation and
really changing people's attitudes about
about infection about infectious
diseases and about hygiene and so it led
to
disinfection the idea of sterilization
or
Oh hygiene and of course food
preparation techniques it's a super
point we get into the 20th century
important things like antibiotics and
transplants and pacemakers our usual
hearts and cat-scans we're a decayed
smallpox in 1988 we create a bunch more
vaccines but really we get to the 20th
century is when we start to organize
things and we see the emergence of
system and so we start to have tools and
methodologies for the organization of
healthcare and that also leads to their
nutrition
there's better education there's more
economic opportunity for people we begin
to understand the economic cost of
disease and that of course fuels the
commitment and interest in public health
but the other thing that happens in the
20th century in a sort of mid century is
the emergence of the whole field of
systems biology and so citizens biology
is basically new discoveries in biology
led to new questions which we could
start to answer with our new tools like
you know mcc's and bioinformatics and
proteomics using mathematical and
computational models so technology would
allow us to generate the data which
could then be parsed to develop
hypotheses about biology so that's
essentially what systems biology is and
so when the field of genetics erupted
1953 Watson Crick defined the structure
of DNA based on Rosalind Franklin's
imaging work that she never got caught
before and and that explodes the whole
field and creates a whole field of the
study of genomics in 1978
Louise Mallon who was the first
test-tube baby is born and the advent of
IVF and in 1997 Dolly the sheep the
first cloned mammal
is announced to the world so that begins
the study of genomics we begin to study
also the immune system and that sets us
up for the 21st century when we have
five key technologies that really have
led us to what we're calling the new
biological revolution so it starts with
genome sequencing so we sequence read
the first human genome in the year 2003
and at a cost exorbitant cost it started
three billion and cut down to 1 billion
it got some little 100 million you know
the cost of sequencing the human genome
has brought to below $1,000 no you know
we first done takes 60 years for the
cost to drop that much and instead it's
taken six or seven years so this is just
exploding the field so in 2017 we
learned the invented the CRISPR
technology which was an opportunity to
edit the human genome a very low cost
and with much higher level of efficiency
and effectiveness than we'd ever had
before
so the cost of sequencing drops the cost
of synthesizing DNA drops continues to
drops makes the curve of Moore's law
look unimpressive so the impact the cell
eration on innovation cannot be
overstated it really is an extraordinary
explosion of opportunity so we began to
sequence of everything so we speak once
you and genome we sequence cancer tumors
so that helps us find the best way of
treating a particular tumor we're
sequencing bacterial DNA discovering all
about our microbiome we're just we're
sequencing plants we're sequencing food
there's so many things happening with
that technology
the second is imaging technology and you
know advancements in our understanding
of how to work with physics combined
with the artificial intelligence ways we
have of parting the edges that
generating have allowed us to look more
deeply into the body and at a higher
resolution than ever before
so that's enabled us to discover new
cells new pathways new biological
circuits and systems that we didn't even
know existed I know that long now
members have her to talk by memory luc
besson and her company open water you
know thanks to this technology we can
now speak at the resolution of an
individual neuron we can peer inside the
brain and see at the revolution
resolution of one neuron she's got a
product roadmap not just to correct for
neurodegenerative diseases but also to
generate brain computer interfaces and
she's not alone as we know Facebook and
your own neural link which is Elon
Musk's company Brian Johnson has Colonel
there's all sorts of people involved in
the room is to develop brain computer
interfaces and you know our imaging
technology has even allowed us to
discover all new cells literally just
last week we just discovered new time
cells in the human hippocampus when
they'd light up we can see that the
brain is actually processing episodic
memories so we're still discovering new
cells certain technology sensors there's
chemical sensors there are biological
sensors there are electronic sensors so
we have sensors in our watches I have
one in my ring you know you can have
them in your shirt you can tell them in
your babies pepper you can have them in
a contact lens or continuous glucose
monitoring you can have it and better
than your tooth this is a very promising
technology where the sensor is actually
measuring everything that you eat and
drink and consume and economies because
getting an accurate and truthful record
of what somebody is actually consume it
is extremely difficult and so if we have
the ability to capture that data
learn a whole lot more about nutrition
and way the body processes those inputs
more about sensors so in November of
2017 the FDA approved the first drug in
the United States with a digital
ingestion tracking system so it's
literally a pill that notes when it's
been swallowed because the splash
stomach acid sends a signal to his cell
phone to indicate that the patient has
taken a pill unfortunately this
particular application was designed for
people with schizophrenia who already
suffered from paranoid delusions that
having a pill it's keeping track of them
it's maybe not the best use of the
technology but nevertheless that exists
and is a technology that we will see
more frequently our sensors are not just
recording our vital signs episodic
moments but it's actually constant
real-time changes your biological
process big data and machine learning
the sensors are generating huge amounts
of data that we are now being able to
feed into our models so that we have
neural networks and machine learning and
AI that allows us to predict not only
who will get this DS but what the
project the progression of the disease
might be which drugs might be most
likely to help this is particularly
difficult in mental health where at
least 65% of the drug tried aren't going
to work in other words only a one in
three chance of the first drug can you
try for your depression will actually be
effective and we're hoping with these
models we can move beyond correlations
to actually the cause of disease so we
need to keep feeding it data and finally
the last thing I like to use smart
phones you know along comes in the year
2007 you know that the iPhone which
allows us to collect more data to keep
patients and doctors in communication
with each other which increases the
insurance to protocols it decreases
recidivism and things like
addiction and it becomes this
magnificent distribution network which
we will find very useful in this
pandemic so I switch we're going to talk
about the current response there's three
companies that I want to call out what
does ginkgo Bioworks the organism
company that basically uses the bacteria
to generate flavors and tastes odors
from spook holes if done this
extraordinary pivot and are used in
their platform to avoid twenty five
million dollars worth of value for code
nineteen response you know they are
doing so in a way to support the
development of testing and gnostics
treatments therapeutics and of course
vaccines and it's kind of an amazing
thing because they're doing it in a
completely open way where they will be
sharing the intellectual property you
will be sharing their research results
and they're really showing us how about
today's molecular biologists and thirty
biologists and scientists really across
the world are basically ignoring
corporate boundaries they're ignoring
you know academic boundaries they're
ignoring national boundaries and sharing
information in most inspiring way and
then there's this company what they are
not because it's not just inspiring but
hopefully we're going to actually see
some results you know there are 78 at
last count two days all this information
78 vaccines in development right now for
code 19 a vaccine platform turns out to
be a really core technology Madera has a
am sorry a mess of the RNA platform for
vaccine development and they were
working on all sorts of different drugs
they've done it of course another
massive pivot to focus their energy on
one in particular called mRNA 1273 which
is their candidate for Koated nights
need and I just
show you what's amazing about this
so there's using this messenger RNA
science to basically create a new class
of medicines that turn your body into a
drug manufacturing engine so the
medicines direct the body cells to
produce proteins that can either attack
a disease or prevent one so normally a
vaccine takes ten years to develop and
in fact most of them fail in recent
years things have been getting much
better from the initial viral sequence
to the launch of phase 1 testing in
humans it took 20 months in 2003 for for
the first SARS outbreak for this Deek
outbreak in 2016 it took just over three
months but here you'll see that from
sequence to a vaccine ready for human
clinical trials happen in just 42 days
and literally from the the first
definition all the way through to a
Phase one approved IND reviewed clinical
trial at 63 days so people have high
hopes or madonna's kovat 19 vaccine and
we'll see what happens the University of
Washington has done great things you
know they actually saw an opportunity to
use CRISPR to cut down the amount of
time it was taking to process the
Diagnostics the testing the PCR based
testing and so once they figured out how
to do that take it for 24 hours to just
a few hours they wanted to be able to
deploy it rapidly but of course they're
an academic institution and not set out
to receive the public at all so not only
did they have the innovation of cutting
down the process in time for these PCR
tests
they also the innovation of turning
their their parking garage into a
drive-through clinic and so patients
could come in and get their swab and
drop it off and be going again and it's
just a blur example of this
extraordinary innovation that
happening in these fields you know at
the leading edge of science and that the
trailing edge of you know how do we
actually get tests in people's hands
it's incredibly inspiring and exciting
and it's also leading to a real
explosion in the opportunity for
telehealth you know how the health has
been around for a long time but there
have been institutional barriers within
regulatory barriers and just people's
attitudes to them both on the part of
the doctor and on the part of the
patient the last thing patients want to
do right now is go sitting in a doctor's
office or go to the hospital because
you're much more likely to get sick in
those places then by staying at home so
we're really seeing this extraordinary
explosion of of youth of these
telemedicine opportunities and I just
want to give you a glimpse of the future
book this is a company called I
apologize I forgot to write it down I
think it's called penguin lung there's
something like that if you pay me I can
I can clarify that for you but this is a
way that Chinese government in this
company penguin have come up with for
addressing the medical needs of people
in rural China so you open the door
close it you sit down you have a a tell
commission a telemedicine consultation
with your doctor on a video screen and
when you're done you can come out and
the doctor will dispense the medication
that he thinks is going to be pure for
your ailment and I thank you your QR
code for a little beach at Debit the
whole thing looks like to need medicine
them they feature so I want to switch
gears a little bit and talk about
engineers who are coming into the
medical sphere and having enormous
influence and this woman is
extraordinary Angela Belcher used to
work in energy and nanomaterials now she
makes vital materials and and she really
works at that intersection for organic
and inorganic interfaces
so she basically is able to reprogram a
virus so that it binds to these
nanotubes and the nanotubes are
attracted to target proteins on cancer
cell
so she ingest them into a mouse body at
this point and then can be she activate
the nanotubes with her red light which
causes them to fluoresce to allow the
surgeon to actually see the fluorescing
cells we are the tomb cells because the
nanotubes are attached to the cancer
cells which enables the surgeon to
actually cut away those cells and then
this extraordinary particularly for the
application she's using it for which
very in cancer
so women fewer than half of the women
who develop ovarian cancer survive more
than five years and the reason for that
is that it often has spread in ways that
surgeons can't see though she's able to
cut the fatality rates in mice by 40%
but she's gonna keep going she's
cheating for 80% so we're able to
reprogram viruses were able to Ernest
bacteria were able to command these
biological entities and systems to do
what we want them to do one of the
favorite examples this company called my
Genesis and comedy was based on
technology and research done by aeroclub
gas at the University of Pittsburgh
where he essentially figured about how
to convert our lymph nodes into many bio
reactors and so basically they can feed
stem cells into our lymph nodes and
induce those stem cells to grow into
functional livers basically at wherever
the site of the lymph nodes are around
the body you know it would only be used
in late stage liver disease but it's
ordinary it's incredibly creative and
innovative and mind-blowing and they're
currently working in large animal models
right now in preparing for human
clinical trials now this could
completely obsolete our existing
transplant system by allowing us to
basically grow compatible organs you
know right now there are 17 thousand
people every year in the United States
waiting for a liver but you only perform
about five thousand liver transplants
per year and as a result about 1,700
patients every year die waiting for a
liver and this could be completely
transformative and on time today to talk
about chimeras you basically using pigs
to grow organs that can then be
harvested for transplant but that's
another thing is completely mind-blowing
because what I want to talk about is
moving from observation to treatment
once we start using genomics to
anticipate and diagnose disease much
more quickly we can transition from a
treatment modality to a prevention
modality and I think our society and are
concerned about health and wellness and
exercise the diet nutrition sleep and
all of those things are going to convert
us into a prevention methodology for
maximizing health so I don't have time
to talk about that either because what I
really want to talk about is design and
what we're moving into is the phase of
biological design that we've only
imagined in science fiction before mr.
beau and Zhou who we actually write
about a burning book he wants to design
custom micro biomes because he
understands that the microbiome is the
source of disease and so if we can
understand that we can diagnose and
predict many chronic metabolic diseases
we can also find potential
your work quickly better we understand
huh
and he sauce excuse me interested in
creating whole new class of
pharmaceuticals that would be based on
the chemicals produced by micros
metabolic processes it's kind of
extraordinary way to think so we're
designing microbiomes we're designing
that race this is Steve Ramirez Steve is
a professor assistant professor at
Boston University and his technology is
based on infusing the brains neurons
with a particular light-sensitive
protein that makes it possible to either
activate or deactivate certain spells
with pulses of light so he basically
uses up the genetics to erase specific
memories in mouse brains he can erase
those memories he can enhance the
memories or diminished in the race he
can even install new memories that the
mouse never had before
his work has profound implications for
humans of the future clearly for
treatment possibility for neurological
disorders like Parkinson's disease like
Alzheimer's etc but what about the use
of of this for post-traumatic stress
disorder in soldiers preparing them to
go back into battle I know this sounds
like a black mirror episode but Steve's
commitment and and his fervent desire is
to keep this technology in the clinical
setting to treat people who are
suffering then there's George church
also featured in our book George is
probably the most inventive bio engineer
of our times he's maintaining this
invest I think there's about 50 alleles
and genes on here but to enhance humans
ccr5 which figured in the CRISPR baby
experiment for HIV protection is also
been shown to have cognitive benefits
there's a grin to be gene which is
associated with learning and memory
there's Hertz which is associated with
longer telomeres in longevity there's PE
for B which is associated with boost
anxiety and then there's sirtuins
SR sir2 has been associated with
increased disease resistance and
therefore potentially extended lifespan
but there's a hole in their list of
edits that we could make to prepare
humans for space battle so that might
include lrp 5 which gives you extra
strong bones or there's four different
mutations combined that can increase the
resistance to radiation or you might
simply use pre-implantation genetic
screening to find the embryos that are
going to be selected for small stature
which would be helpful if you're crammed
inside a tiny little space capsule there
are genes or mental emotional resilience
so if you're going to be alone for an
extended period of time in space or if
you're going to be with a bunch of other
astronauts in a small space for an
extended period of time we could select
for the emotional qualities for that you
might also select for low order
production and low body overproduction
you know George it's working on the
science for this Danny Hillis of course
well now founder and brilliant genius an
amazing human being wrote a fiction
piece based on the actual science where
the couple walk in and have a
consultation with a genetic counselor in
the future and he talks about the fact
that you know your children may find
extra appendages is very useful people
get excited about tails they have their
pluses and minuses but you know it's
just all appendages could be quite handy
and then he goes through a series of
accessories and add-ons and basically
UPS else the genetic counselor might
trying to no convinced you to go for he
is about aesthetics and how parents
could get suckered into or trapped into
something that's a little too trendy
that just feels uploaded 10 or 15 years
later but oh ever you genitally did like
to express that feature even Eagleman
another one now board member has a piece
of our book about the possible remorse
we may have as parents for some of these
choices
you know there's designer organs company
honey COO has designed the brain on a
chip
asha gabby is fellow developing a
neurons silicon hybrid chip you know
right now it's being used for chemical
sensing but in the future it could be
used for pharmaceutical development it
could be used for consumer products it
could be used for defense applications
but this fusing between biology and
electronics is it's actually happening
in a bunch of print companies there's
another comfortable cortical labs in
australia what they really might be
developing here is the first black bear
artificial intelligence so these are
companies that we want to keep Milian
these are developments that we should
understand it and and be aware up and
keep an eye on they're kind of like
promising and they're credibly powerful
and i think we need to understand the
vets between the two I'm going to go
quickly through a few other major
projects that should be on your radar
screen in terms of potential
transformations of of our humans and
that the first one is the human self
atlas so this is a comprehensive
reference map of all the human cells in
order to understand and to monitor to
diagnose and treat disease it's
interesting to me that in the year 2020
we still don't even know how many
different
types of cells there are and so this
project is is super interesting Chan
Zuckerberg the European bioinformatics
Institute the Brodus to that Harvard T
University of California Santa Cruz
they're all involved in that we're
trying to map the brain the connectome
there's Obama's initiative called the
brain which is an attempt to map it and
then there's the European human brain
project which is an attempt to actually
build a functioning model of the brain
it's the connectome then there's the
proteome there was a paper in nature not
too long ago where scientists are
working to map all of the proteins we
don't have any idea how many proteins
that are this particular effort is
mapping 12,000 proteins we think there
could be anywhere from eighty to 400,000
but it depends on how you define them so
the proteome is something that we're
tracking and then a project I'm super
interested in is the idea of tracking
the amino m-- there's an organization
called the human vaccines project and
they are a non-profit clinical research
consortium we're open source they're
partnered with many institutions through
NGOs the pharmaceutical companies and
and biotech partners and they're mining
computing and artificial intelligence
with genomics system biology
epidemiology biology and bioinformatics
so they're trying to complete the
genetic sequencing of the human immune
system so that they can understand how
it fights disease with the global of
ultimately creating a machine learning
based model of the human immune system
they've just announced this amazing
initiative of two days ago the human
immune omics initiative with Harvard's
champ oat School at the School of Public
Health and this is to generate a
high-powered model of immunity and they
want to accelerate the design and
testing of vaccines and therapeutics
the particular focus on the principles
of effective immunity for in ancient
populations obviously those must pose
for Co in nineteen but this is all big
science and big academia and well funded
medical startups but you know the tools
of biology are busting out all over the
place and are being used in people in
ways that you might not be so aware of
you know right now that's being taught
at postgraduate level you could do this
as graduate level work soon this will
probably become undergraduate level
molecular biology but I've imagined a
time in the not-too-distant future when
it's being taught in high schools or
let's see me be on YouTube and that
brings me to the kinds of bio hackers
that we have already out there this is
still Ark who's been doing body
modifications for decades now in this
particular project he grew an ear and
has inserted it in his forearm and is
now working on embedding a microphone
connecting the microphone to the
Internet and have it be a permanent
listening post which is kind of amazing
he's actually a professor with an
appointment at the alternate anatomies
laboratory at Curtin University in
Australia then there's a the Odin a San
Francisco based company that will sell
you a DIY CRISPR kit this particular kit
goes for one thousand nine hundred and
ninety nine dollars but you can get all
of the ingredients the reagents and and
materials you need for only $169 this
one is expensive because it actually
includes a PCR machine so this is a very
consumer friendly price point and he has
a growing business of selling the
cemented people who are figuring out
what
can do this in their own homes or
classrooms for whatever reason they may
have and I want to show what artists are
doing with this scene Ida pockets is a
writer and an artist but he's a
molecular biologist and the creative
director at eco bio works they were
talking about what the smell of an
extinct flower might be so she sequenced
this plant sent it off to the Paleo
genomics lab who CSCE
they came back with the DNA sequence
which codes for particular proteins
which would then produce certain enzymes
which would have certain olfactory
characteristics they hired an artist in
blending sisal told us an old country
artist who blended those aromatics
together to produce what perfume would
be and then they collaborated with
amazing artists Daisy Ginsberg on and
installation for Milano Vienna and the
public center in Paris that's been
submitted all over the places kind of a
mighty expanding project that makes you
think well good we can preserve these
things than they can always be brought
back it's the life but perhaps there's a
moral hazard issue here does it allow us
to drive things into extinction because
we know we can always bring them back if
we need them the interesting questions
that artists ask us to consider Lynn
personally Lisa in the San
francisco-based artists filmmaker whose
work it has always been at the leading
edge of science and technology in this
case she has interwoven her art and her
artistic archive with the space and
technology of antibody fabrication so
she collaborated with Novartis to
actually produce an antibody developed
based on the letters in her name you're
staying the powder essence of that
antibody heater she also encoded her
entire artistic archive of films and
foes and other
humans into DNA for all eternity which
opens up the intriguing possibility of
you know the ultimate artistic comeback
this artist Heather Dewey had picked a
seek cigarette butts in done chewing gum
and hair samples left behind sequence
them and then projected phenotypes based
on the sequencing information these are
portrait masks that she did and her work
is really interesting you should see
what she did with Chelsea Manning's DNA
but the project that I'm most interested
in right now is one of her more recent
projects which is called lovesick the
transfection and in this case she
partnered with an antibody discovery
company to design a custom retrovirus
which was designed to increase the
production of oxytocin oxytocin the
neurotransmitter that we released when
they stopped punched based on a hug or
kiss an orgasm or breastfeeding so she
wanted to have a true virus that would
increase the production of oxytocin to
spread feelings of affection and
attachment and to come back the
alienation of the present so she calls
this love sickness I think of it as
perhaps the quarantine sickness perhaps
we all need some of that but these are
the questions that were grappling with
and we heard these incredibly powerful
technologies you know we are as gods so
we may as well get good at it as Stewart
Vermont once famously said you know but
the problem is we have Paleolithic
emotions medieval institutions and
godlike technology as the socio
biologists he looks at once said so how
do we overcome our Paleolithic emotions
and our medieval institutions to deploy
these godlike technologies in a way that
enhances our experience
and our relationship to each other into
the planet and who gets to decide these
things you know China and India are the
largest and fastest growing populations
on the planet you know they're more
likely to be making choices that impact
our species than any cup opium in London
or Tokyo or Boston and rather than asked
whose values should guide us we want to
ask a more open-ended question which is
what values do we need to guide us in
turning a biological future perhaps we
should ask Imhotep our Egyptian
physician philosopher priest and
architect you know because that's the
kind of thinking that's the kind of
interdisciplinary design thinking that
we need to bring to the future of our
species you know I noticed that many of
our notable computer scientists have
studied philosophy I think is
encouraging it reminds me of Danny
Hillis you know who said I'd like a bill
to build a computer that would be proud
of me or I hope that whenever comes
after that is proud of us how do we be
good and dusters you know this is the
classic long now question and you know
tonight I'm here to talk about how we're
framing that issue and the progress that
we have made so far and I want to ask
the long nail community you know these
very important questions and here I just
have to stop and acknowledge the missing
partner in the room of my co-editor
Brian Bernstein Brian was the executive
editor for many years at the MIT
Technology Review and the founding
editor of neo life three years ago and
my co-editor on the book and I have to
say that his breadth of knowledge and
perspective and editorial acumen and
prowess have really made me laugh
possible he's based in Boston so it's
late there but were we not all under
lockdown he would be with me hopefully
here
but Brian and I have been thinking about
a manifesto for the future of our
species and we've engaged a number of
thinkers and innovators and scientists
and artists you know on the topic and
it's quite possible that and it ought to
craft something like you know as
ingenious a document as manifesto for
the future future of our species we just
be you know the ultimate act of hubris
but it's going to be worthless unless
literally everybody weighs in and we
know that there's a lot to be gained
from the effort so we are curious on
nature and it is in our nature to make
tools and we will make these tools we
will pursue these lines of research so
through technology we have already
extended our locomotion our senses our
cognitive ability and we've even
asserted control over the very creation
of life with birth control in vitro
fertilization and all the other tools of
Advanced reproductive technology so like
it or not this is the ultimate
definition of progress and you people at
the seminar are in one of the few who
are uniquely positioned to understand
where these tools might take us the
directions and the decisions that we
make now about which technologies to
develop how they're designed how we
productize them how we price them and
how we bring them to market these
decisions are going to be having lasting
impacts and what we have imagined
because what we build if we move too
fast we risk unintended consequences and
backlash from patients and consumers and
regulators and religious groups and
political upheaval and more chaos but if
we move too slow if we choose not to
pursue some of these possibilities
like for instance eliminating
genetically inherited diseases
well then feels like a crime against
humanity
I mean what if your great-grandchild
sues Kurt parents for not genetically
engineering her to protect her from
disease or to protect or to give her
advantages that other people have been
given because their parents it she's the
genetic enhancements so maybe she's
genetically a different competing
effectively how are we going to tell the
difference between these choices and
these decisions these are not easy
questions and the think people thought
was we just saw run a unnatural forty
years ago like test-tube babies you know
might not be considered not only normal
but a basic human right so the things
that we're shocked by today how many of
those are going to be basic human rights
in another 40 years or twenty years or
ten years so this is what we're working
on at Neil life and if you'd like to
follow in Congress you can check out our
website at www.nasa.gov
so you can follow us on Facebook or
Twitter or Instagram or LinkedIn and
we've just published a series of these
visions which were conversations from
scientists and science fiction writers
and artists that I talked about tonight
you can buy a book on the website at neo
life slash visions and if you do please
use the code long now so we know to
donate 25% of the book revenues to the
organization that we email life and the
now community will together dues to
support those people most at risk from
an artist by this pandemic so you won't
realize that we are not humanity's mail
creation
you know how much sapiens at the top of
the food chain in the 21st century is an
enormous flinch
but it brings with it an obligation and
some awesome responsibilities so you
should have to take and our question for
you is what is your vision for the
future of our species thank you thank
you so much Jen
that was a it was an amazing survey that
I think you know so many so many people
in this field and so many fields are are
focused on a very narrow spectrum of
what they're working on and in many
cases they don't actually have a chance
to take a step back and realize that
they are a field and I think this is one
of those spaces I think we saw so saw
this you know with the extinction was
there was many people working in 2d
extinct species but didn't realize that
they were part of a field until we
brought them together as a as a
conference and I think what you're doing
with neo life is in this same space and
I think it's very important to to for
these various scientists as well as the
public to kind of understand that this
is a burgeoning field it's happening in
some cases without any of our kind of
input and and clearly the ethical
concerns as well as the societal
concerns are ones that we all want to
participate in and I think what you've
done with neo life is is allowing us
into that and I think you know a
parallel to our current situation that I
I think is important it's a conversation
that Kevin Kelley and I were having
recently is that fundamentally mostly
scientific consensus usually happens
where people argue because scientists
argue about things right papers their
review their peer-reviewed those all of
those things happen over years and that
scientific consensus comes to some
question you know kind of a consensus
and what we're seeing now I think this
is there's a parallel to this in both
genetic genetic modification world as
well as a synthetic biology world where
is the with kovat where we're watching
science happen in real time and we're
watching scientists
conflict with each other in real time
we're watching various press outlets
pick up you know a given voice and then
put it out there but I think this
happens in synthetic biology in the
world that you're working in Sabbath's
and genetic modification as well and I
just wanted to get a sense from you if
you could reflect on you know the
controversial nature of and kind of in a
way sensationally sensationalistic
nature of synthetic biology as well as
the kind of work that's happening out
for Cova door these other things and and
how how the scientists are dealing with
that and learning to figure this out
it's unfortunate the way media works
because the sensationalism is what gets
people's attention we have an
opportunity to then explain go more
deeply into what's actually happening
and what's the reality behind it
you know I've been concerned that you
know anti-vaxxers and anti GMO
compensations would dominate where we
were going when these tools and look
accomplished with these tools and I
think the pandemic has given us an
opportunity to really see science its
best the way people can collaborate the
way they can come together for a common
good but I think it's important that we
take a step back and realize that you
know while these tools of
transformational and give us
opportunities to do things we've never
done before in a sense they're on a
continuum of other tools that have
transformed our our species if you look
back to you know the printing press the
Gooden Berg press suddenly started to
read and you know what if the impact on
the brain ban of lunacy
you know same thing with the internet
you know my kids grew up with access to
all the world's information with Khan
Academy and YouTube you know readily
available to them to answer any question
they had
but effective sentiment Burton if you
look at University Professors today
they're saying that kids coming into
their classrooms know way more than they
could ever have imagined you know and
their brains are used to jumping from
you know a scientific paper to a YouTube
video to you know a video game and in
each one of these instances they're
learning something is impacting their
brains and it's preparing them for this
interdisciplinary world we're thinking
to coming at us from all these different
angles you have to be able to see and
pick up on opportunities and you know
the thing that impresses me the most
about synthetic biology is that but you
have these basic tools of molecular
biology genetic engineering being able
to heart bacteria and viruses and and
that sort of thing you know question is
what I'm going to do with it and I think
our scientists today are being asked to
to take their immense tool sets right I
mean they do 10 or 15 years of deep
study to get their MD or their PhD and
they also have to be you know
essentially computer hackers they have
to be incredibly digitally literate and
they have to understand something about
a on I mean it is true that we're all
becoming far more interdependent because
no one person can understand all of that
but the people who can be an expert in
one field and then Venter into a new
field as a novice bringing that skillset
with them you know that's one of the
thinking that we need going forward to
have them kind of breakthroughs people
like Angela Melchior and others are
showing us the way for indeed I think I
mean so much of the history that you you
talked about is really the history of
tools you know you have 400 years ago
the advent of the microscope and then
the you know kind of early genetic
modifications PCR test tube babies you
know which were highly contentious until
the first baby was actually unseen and
then there was this cute baby and then
all of a sudden the controversy of
test-tube baby
went off the map and I think we're gonna
see a lot of similar things with various
genetic modifications and and some of
these other issues but I'm curious as as
you talked with all of these biologists
and Technology kind of inventors it was
there is there a next technology that
that they were looking at or excited
about that that isn't ready yet that it
is going to enable another wave already
and our technology is front of our
science and so I think sort of
innovation and what most of the people
that we're talking to now are thinking
about is how will a I transform their
understanding of what they're trying to
accomplish
so basically almost every field I can
think of is there they're saying the
same things which is you know if it's
optogenetics it's like hey you know what
else can I do with optogenetics if it's
artificial intelligences how is that
going to transform things I mean I think
we are in a period now where it's less
about huge new unanticipated
technologies and it's more about taking
the technologies we currently have and
using those understand our biology
better than we currently do oh that's
that's pretty interesting state of
things yeah well I guess the debt that's
now or some theory that you know our
technology is out in front of us pants
and her business is about firmware
technology you know because we saw with
the consumer genetics for instance we
didn't really have we had the technology
and we start these businesses but you
know the science wasn't there you know
and people started getting oh my
sequence mcdu you know but this company
and it didn't say this thing is that
company and indicates what to do with
this information and you know I thought
core doesn't know what to do with it and
you know entertainment value is limited
so yeah so I big shoes to fill up back
now and you know with those you know the
connectome and in you know the proteome
you know the human cell atlas there's so
much we don't know and we've got these
amazing tools right now so you know yes
we'll they'll be next gen sequencing for
sure I mean the sequencing is now dead
there's this machine called the Oxford
nanopore which is literally a pocket
sequencer you know the fact that we can
do PCR now in less than 24 hours I mean
it's right now I think it's about those
types of advances more than a whole new
field that we've never heard of before
that's going to come in and completely
transform everything but we're time to
process all of that tensile strength
will get faster but you know we've got a
lot of science to do nice well yeah it
seems those tools are now they're moving
faster than even Moore's law and so just
keeping up with those it's like because
I got all these conferences we see the
same slide which is the cost of
sequencing like this and then worst law
going like this you know it's like right
but way off of the Moore's Law chart
which seemed like the the fastest thing
that we could imagine but clearly
biology is now moving faster and I think
I mean I think you pointed out a lot of
things that are happening now without
our intervention without a lot of
discussion and but I'm curious what are
the things that you personally are most
concerned about you know I think there's
a lot of these things that are just
gonna happen and we're gonna catch up
with them kind of as they applications
really at the market but as as you have
done a survey of all this what is what
are some of the things that you feel as
though you would like to either have
more discussion about intervention about
or be in front of before those
applications hit the market
about the possibilities as I am
concerned about the distortion of the
potential you know and live through the
digital revolution
you know I saw our vision to become
reality
and I also saw them get distorted by
business models that were no longer
really in the best interest of us as
individuals and societies and so I can
imagine that coming out again which is
why I'm starting a life essentially a I
think it's incredibly interesting and
fascinating it's going to have an
enormous impact and B there will be
enormous well created and C there will
be enormous disruption and so what did
we learn from the digital revolution you
know one thing that's clear to me is
that as long as everybody's making money
you know there was there was a little
call for regulation and by the time it
became apparent that there was need for
regulation in a certain sense there's
too late and the companies were already
too big and it's hard to to shift that
direction but this is different this is
life and death and these are people's
personal burdens you know to bear in the
physical emotional and psychological way
and it's a highly regulated world that
we are now entering into and so I'm
worried almost about too much regulation
at the same time I'm so worried about
not enough of the right kind of
regulation and and that's why I feel
like we need to just start with
education you need to start with the
realization that these technologies and
tools that are out there they could have
these types of positive benefits they
could have these types of negative ones
you know the thing that people are
really really focused on right now I
think may turn out to be less important
in the grand scheme of things in long
now scheme of things
than others in that is the Nutri privacy
and you know so much has been slowed by
the need to protect Patriot Records from
potential discrimination and I totally
understand that and I support that in
the long run I wonder if the interests
of public health want to proceed our
interests are individual privacy desire
one thing that I worry a lot about our
brain computer interfaces I mean I think
that is a you know to me that's like a
final frontier and that's sort of maybe
that's an extension of privacy but you
know I just need to see how we could
possibly move forward with that kind of
technology in a way that is it just a
real violation of not even necessarily
privacy but like who we are you know
it's like might you know is one thing
and you know you might just go and get
against me because I have the apoe4 gene
for Alzheimer's that's that's something
that we can deal with regulation and
consumer protections and so forth but
once you start you know looking inside
my head I think that's really kind of a
scary one indeed and I think I'm gonna
move over to some of the questions that
we're getting from our various feeds out
in the public and I think we've had
several questions that I think relate to
the basically the socioeconomic status
of how this will roll out into the world
and you know while we may have you know
one to two thousand dollar crisper hits
the way some of these things you know
choices about your kids I color and
predispositions for IQ and things like
that clearly aren't going to have a an
even roll out into the world but are
there other worries that you have in the
space of how these things may be
distributed absolutely how they're
priced who has accessed you know also so
it
who is it a matter of having to keep up
you know it's like you may know may not
want that cognitive enhancement but if
you don't get it you won't get a job as
a computer programmer no I think these
the kinds of very stark sort of black
and white choices that people will be
confronted with in the future you know
which is why concepts of universal
healthcare of universal basic income go
hand in hand with visions of the future
because they conveniently erase you know
those types of inequities you know I
don't know that I have an answer and you
know what I understand our economic
forces as they have worked until now and
what I also understand is the technology
will transform us in ways that might
update the entire capitalist structure
if we need far less land and water and
other inputs to grow our food we grow
the things we need materials and the
furniture and the food medicines you
know we have 3d printers where we can
just download a file and print out you
know the vaccine or the or the food or
you know the next thing that I need the
next border I need for my spaceship
you know these things start to become so
outside our current experience that it's
hard to connect the dots so that's what
we're trying to do is like understand
where we are with these technologies how
long they're going to take to develop
how long it will be until they're
deployed and then just imagine the the
economic models that go along with that
dude so Kevin Kelley has another
question I think so he asked described
the most optimistic neo biological
future that you can imagine in a century
from now you know we can imagine that
public health
is going to require all of our genomes
to be sequenced that will be there long
before that but I think the you know
making that as an assumption that that
that so much of our genetic information
is going to become part of the
healthcare system and that it will also
include some of the advantages that can
be that can be put out there are there
what what do you imagine as some of the
greatest benefits that you that you want
you know as your own self or as a as a
mother of other children you know what
are what are what are some of your
thoughts on the future of this
genetically inherited diseases have been
eliminated if we have a disease we
quickly know how to treat it because we
sequence you at birth we understand what
your risk factors are and you know we
have rapid vaccine and we have fertile
rabbit testing of rapid therapeutic
development and we have prediction
models so we can basically address
disease
I imagine that we have converted from
industrial manufacturing from extracted
economies to bio manufacturing and to
growing things with living systems so we
as a result of that have able to clean
up my planet we are living and continuum
with all the other biological systems on
the planet and so we are no longer
extracting of polluting but court seeing
in interpreting and and growing things
in a way that puts us the more
sustainable physician I mean to me that
is that's the vision I think right now
one at Reiki has this magnificent essay
in our book where he talks about the
fact that
no it's 1/10 of 1% difference in the DNA
between you know me and somebody you
know from a tribe in Africa and yet you
know we don't deal with even that level
of diversity very well you know what I
think we can look forward to I'm super
excited about is a greater species
diversity among confidence and I look
forward to the fear of those differences
going away because there's so many
benefits to having more diversity you
know that's it's kind of a way to future
the proof on an ecosystem is is to have
more diversity right it's monocultures
there are at great risk and so maybe we
need more types of codes if that's what
we care about who's protecting hominids
we have to consider the possibility that
global warming may not good for Homo
sapiens but you know what you know
Wilson basically said you know if homo
sapiens were wiped out there's very few
other species that would be negatively
impacted whereas if you wiped out the
ants you know it would completely
destroy entire ecosystems so I think
that's something we have to sort of
consider yeah well I think we're living
through an interesting moment where the
homo sapiens have been relegated to
their homes and we're starting to see
that natural world coming back in all
kinds of interesting ways
yeah well the Coyotes are for sure
coming back I can attest from my own
neighborhood they've become quite more
brave but I think yeah as a follow-up to
to that last question I think some of
the decisions that we make in the
synthetic biology space are going to be
heritable versus inheritable and that's
a pretty big question right like so two
questions you make for yourself or even
your kids versus their kids are that
becomes a vastly bigger question of if
your kids or your grandkids are saddled
with a question that you were trying to
solve for
you know some very localized problem
that you had in terms of time and space
versus the questions that they have for
their own generations years into the
future you know we can imagine that
maybe they will have the ability to undo
them but maybe they don't but I just
wanted to touch base on this kereta ball
versus inheritable questions and where
we're either both the scientists that
you've worked with as well as yourself
feel about that right well I mean I
think that is the that's a huge
unanswerable question how could we
possibly make decisions on behalf of
humans that haven't been born yet I just
don't see a way to work through the
legal issues surrounding that but our
attitudes about these things change and
you know today's legal system our
understanding of you know our rights as
individuals our natural rights you know
as a little concept that it's back you
know hundreds of years might not pertain
in the future and I think you know using
today's ethics to anticipate that our
this is impossible you know I think for
us one of the tenets of our manifesto
but for the future of our species could
be something along the lines of we
should never test something in the
germline if we could test it in somatic
cells first in other words you know do
things that are restricted to just one
generation and that do not persist
across future generations I think that's
about to be sort of a basic
understanding for now until we
understand more what the consequences of
our actions are and and or until our our
attitudes than our understanding and our
society changed yeah I think that's a
terrifying prospect yeah I mean I think
you know there's
it seems kind of simple in concept to to
say that we don't want to affect the
germline but when it comes to like
removing let's say if you're removing
Alzheimer's from the germline and so you
know right now we would assume that that
is a totally reasonable assumption and I
can't imagine how it will feature a shin
but but that is you know you're you're
now you're now limiting yourself from
being able to to remove something like a
genetic disease that that would have so
much benefit going forward and so maybe
every generation has to make that
decision for themselves
here's thing so it's two responses to
that one is we do not have to do a
germline edit to remove Alzheimer's we
could simply do embryo selection right
so if you've got that gene you know
we're just not going to implant that and
you know right now is something like 1
to 2 percent of births in this country
come through in vitro fertilization you
know the numbers are much higher in
places like Norway and and sweeping ugly
in Finland the Nordic country you know
with some of the big tech companies
offering women the opportunity to freeze
their eggs and offering couples the
opportunity to freeze their embryos once
you've got multiple embryos he's kind of
a no-brainer to the sequence than to
choose the ones you want and so I can
see us in that way genetically
manipulating our species in a way that
doesn't require cut into the germline
it's just a matter of who we selected
again that's that is even on a continuum
of you know we tend to choose people who
are racially and socially and you know
economically similar to ourselves so
we're doing that already we just now
have slightly different tools for doing
it and we may find ourselves selecting
embryos that don't have the risk of
Alzheimer's disease but they don't have
the risk of you know the
illness and bipolar disorder which you
know could have tremendous implications
for our society going forward since such
a huge percentage of our created class
actually suffered from from those
problems and then you that's part of
what makes them you know the creative
genius so you know we're already doing
this the question is how much more
efficient and effective doing tools yet
and how big an impact will this have
overall inin species
indeed now we have a question actually
here from Ryan Phelan and Stuart brand
and I think it actually has a larger it
has a larger context to the current
situation but I think also to the
technologies you're describing which is
that as people get enhanced you know
they're going to be different from the
ones that are unenhanced they're going
to have some kind of advantages let's
say and do we want to document them
differently in society and I think that
you know going back to Stuart and Ryan's
question to the present situation we're
about to be in a situation where I
suspect and you know they're asking
about which is that we're going to have
wristbands or you know some equivalent
thing to the people that have been
exposed to Cova didn't have antibodies
and I have a in a way an advantage in
current civilization where they can
interact in a way that the people who
don't have those antibodies can't
interact so or were strangely faced with
the situation vastly sooner I think then
then we would then if let's say you know
people had had an IQ advantage that was
somehow inherently put into their
genetics and would they have a wristband
how are people talking about this in the
field that you know of I think even to
back this up a little bit is how are the
scientists in these fields talking about
ethics ethical questions at the scale
you know that you have seen aside from
just continuing to do their work in the
labs
last party question first which is they
have very few venues for expressing
those ideas and those thoughts and you
know the bioethics field in general is
sort of prescribed and it tends to be
relegated to one field if one type of
scientific endeavor whereas in fact
these implications are interdependent
and at the moment and then where they
connect to other fields the fewer
opportunities there are to discuss that
one notable example or difference there
CRISPR technology and there's a lot of
ways in which that technology has United
scientists across all these different
fields to come together and have
conversations about what we can do with
CRISPR whether it's in a medical field
or pharmaceutical field and a cultural
field or what-have-you
I think short I think scientists are
definitely interested in these
conversations totally want to have them
I mean I've heard from scientists who
say we do not want to make these choices
you know don't make our values the
prevailing ones we think everybody
should be engaged in understanding these
technologies certainly been a broad
cross-section of inputs about how to use
this point forward um you know - your
idea - of or to the question about
enhancements I mean if you take an
example like athletes for instance you
know I mean we already have this in a
sense which of our athletes are blood
doping or using steroids or you know
what who knows what modifications they
could already be using that we just
haven't figured out yet
you know will that continue sure I'm
sure that people will do you know silent
or secretive genetic manipulations going
forward and I'm equally sure that there
will be people like the bodybuilders you
know her clearly using banned substances
you know will there'll be the naturals
and then
will there be a social appreciation for
the naturals and you know it's this sort
of slippery
you know unclear line like what is
natural and what is not and you know
that lines gonna keep shifting as you go
forward and so so yes I mean I think
these will be questions that we're
already grappling with and we will
continue to grapple with you know going
forward and they'll get more confusing
I mean it's being a natural better than
being enhanced I think it's your point
of view I think it depends on who you
are what you value and you know we think
on things clearest we're not all going
to value this thing thing which is a
good thing I think and the question too
is you know who's keeping score and what
are you using to keep score and if money
is what you're using to keep score
you know then yeah these things are bad
and people who are enhanced should have
you know additional I know maybe there's
a fantastic Kurt Vonnegut short story
and I believe it was welcome to the
monkey house where it had to take
everybody equal we made the ballerina
where sandbags
they made the genius have crashing
headaches you know it's like are we
headed into a situation like that or you
know can be genetically enhanced genius
be gently enhanced but can the person
who chose to remain natural and perhaps
to artisanal work with their hands you
know some probably equally not our
society and in terms of you know the
pandemic and who's got the antibodies
and who does it that will see this play
out it really shouldn't order I hope
because these hopefully these antibody
tests will be reliable and you can you
know see the response coming off and
yeah those who are able to go back to
work and that money and those who don't
will have to have some other support
systems and mechanisms and maybe this is
exactly the kind of thing that starts to
to change the way
our economies function yeah no I I've
been thinking very much about this I
think the especially if people find out
that having had the disease gives them
antibodies and gives them advantages in
society like being able to go back to
work the number of people that are self
infecting and taking that risk I think
is going to be a really wild form of in
a way synthetic biology taking place in
real time in public that we probably
haven't seen and I'm not sure there may
even already be people doing this but I
think that's going to be a really wild
space and you know unfortunately I think
people obviously will suffer and die in
that and as well as increase the
infection rate to others if they're not
careful doing it and I think that's in a
way it's kind of a microcosm of some of
the things that may play out due to you
know maybe more careful
edits that happen in the future
Kevin Kelley also was asking I think a
kind of the way this is playing out
about in nationalistic ways you know I
know that you know Europe has been so
traditionally against genetic
modification and things like food crops
but so I mean we have other countries
like China and India that seem to be
vastly more open to some especially
China and then Russia we don't know
South America and Africa where or have
you been seeing some of national
concerns play out in the space is there
is there space is there are their
national areas that are moving faster or
slower what's your take on that or just
some of it I mean the new biological
labs that you're talking to I mean I
know most the ones that were in the book
are us-based but are you seeing you know
are those labs worried more about what's
happening in China or India or what's
your take on some of the nationalistic
divides in this space that's what's so
interesting this is where you know I
think diversity will
all of these verticals if you will you
know the the applicants are farmers are
you know very upset that Europeans have
have declared that love foods are non
desirable because you know they're
suffering from banana blight you know
and they're suffering from problems with
their overuse event eggplant circuit
eggplant you know they have a number of
crops that are impacted and for which
there are genetically modifying
alternatives and so they want access to
them that's what they need to feed their
families you know in China you know they
make very different choices about what
it considered a viable embryo there's a
famous example of the CRISPR scientists
international gathering where American
scientist was saying that you know in
America deaf child is not considered
undesirable and that family would
welcome another deaf child into their
culture and the Chinese scientist
famously says we would get to that a
non-viable embryo and you know I think
we cannot come up with woman dictate
that's going to make sense across all
national borders and across all
ethnicities and across all societies and
all cultural and units and I think
that's interesting I think those
differences are going to play out in
ways that ultimately could be beneficial
for our species but I think there will
be things that you know people are
genuinely horrified by indeed all right
so we're coming to our last questions
here I think kind of a two-part question
of you started neo life a number of
years ago and you've been yes three
years ago and you've been you know doing
a fantastic job of connecting with all
the
various scientists and I think even you
doing this has helped them realize that
they are part of a larger field but what
what have you changed your mind about
after starting this process I suspect
that there was all kinds of original
excitement in various parts of this but
are there parts of it that you have
changed your mind about or that you feel
as though you would like to impart the
other half this question is that you
would like to impart back into this
field in terms of either questions or
excitement that you wish would happen
faster and that you know something that
you could maybe modify your own self or
your own next generation with so yeah so
what are what do what have you changed
your mind about what are your highest
concerns and what are your greatest
dreams with this ok so what have I
changed my mind about I was far less
nuanced in my understanding of these
technologies and their benefits and I
was just completely bowled over by the
possibilities of the science and the
technology so thank you anything but
I've changed my mind about us how fast
we could move forward and I think I've
also become a bigger fan of intelligent
regulation than I have ever been before
in my life and I think that's been an
interesting process that I'm still kind
of working through because you know you
say regulation but this regulation back
home and you know are there state
regulations are there federal
regulations are there international
regulations visit all of the same or
their regulations the way a global
community of scientists understand it as
opposed to you know regulations by
country you know that's that's something
that I'm still trying to parse you know
my biggest hope is to eliminate disease
and to
convert us from you know a society where
70% of people who are sick are sick
because of what they eat and how they
live and just a lack of access to clean
food and clean water and an
understanding of you know an ability to
do things that they know will make them
healthier so it kind of starts there
with the health prospects I got into
this through food and mental health and
cognitive decline
those were the three kind of areas that
initially opened my eyes to the way
these technologies were advancing and
you know I think so I think my biggest
hope is to not have you know an epidemic
of people suffering from Alzheimer's to
not have obesity and diabetes and
genetically inherited disease of this
you know taking it a step you one that
is cleaning up our environment by by
harnessing living systems and using
living systems more intelligently
instead of you know chopping things down
and paving them louver and pumping a lot
of chemicals into them I think there's
ways that you know I I was running down
the Colorado River through the Grand
Canyon these giant overs and remember
trying to go in a particular direction
and I wrenched my shoulder it's a 14
foot or with forget with the water
pressure is impaired just sort of
instead
realizing if you just follow the bubbles
in the stream you can just float and
then you just use your oars in these
very small base to kind of adjust and I
would just like to speed homosapiens
figure out how to live in greater
harmony in ways that you know caught but
require fewer inputs you know cause less
damage and pollution and yield higher
results Thanks well I want to thank you
so much
you know we originally scheduled this
talk for a live event at SF jazz center
and we had to delay it but I'm very
excited that we're able to bring this to
a global audience
and and your research and the I want to
say the neo life book is is an amazing
collection of stories from the cutting
edge of all of this that are that are
very personal in a way with some of the
scientists that are doing this work and
I think it's it's an important survey of
this time and space that we're in can
you say again the link in order to order
the book as well as the code for getting
for having the proceeds go to the
charity that we're going to be looking
for yeah so the book is really a time
capsule and so in that sense I think
it's also a great sort of kind of
project sort of capturing this moment in
time what we wish were what are we
afraid of you know how do we imagine
things going forward so I do hope that
people have been answering her question
what elements belong in a manifesto for
the future of our species and I do hope
that people have been given these
recommendations for organizations that
are protecting those most at risk during
this pandemic so if you go to our
website it's WWE neo life and eat L IFE
and if you plug in a code oh so that's
so our website
the current is long now just L Ong and o
W and I'm trying to show you because I
don't think actually show you what the
book looks like so it's actually just
it's not a treatise on synthetic biology
or ethics it it's a beautifully designed
book with lots of imagery and things
inside a neo life slash visions we'll
into the book once you get the neon top
life you can then migrate your way
around and so yeah cool well thank you
so much for doing this it's all new
format I'm excited about doing so many
more of the talks for a long now in this
format and I'm so excited that you were
able to do the first one with us
and slog through our interesting new
technology choices as we do it it's been
a pleasure thank you so much Shane and
thank you so much too long our
membership and sponsors and donors that
that are making all of this continue to
be true and continue to happen even
though we're all relegated to our homes
as it does so thank you so much and
we'll be back we'll be back soon with
our next talk with Lawrence Doyle from
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
we'll be talking about human animal
communication and how that reflects on
our thoughts about how we might interact
with species from other galaxies or even
further out or and so it'll be it'll be
interesting another talk on the future
of our species thank you so much Jane
and thank you everyone June 10
[Music]
you